[Music]
how do you feel about the latest
trend about diversity which is diversity
of visualness
versus diversity of thought diversity of
thought versus visualness so diversity
of how
people different people how they look
yeah because as far as i see
on on campuses it's
let's have whatever whatever population
percentage there are of brown people
they should be in university same with
those that are underprivileged they
should be represented in some way
representation
but it's more it's more a visual
dimension of class race and gender
than what than thought so it's not as if
it's not as if
having a brown person will make this
more diverse
right yes yes exactly so how do you feel
about that
yeah i mean i feel um that uh yeah we
need both and we need we need to think
about across and i actually talk about
that in a way i call the arc of
anti-capitalism
to relate it back to the marxism point
right that that it's many many things
that we have to try to think of think
about how we start connecting across
many different efforts
many different forms of challenging
capitalism
if we understand capitalism as i do is
central
to uh the uh ills
and problems of our planet right now so
uh so that's why so the question is
people
who are different and have different
ideas but are organized around
the notion that capitalism has to be
challenged and has to be
diverted from it has to be moved away
from that's really important so
you know how so if people are not in
that tune but no matter what their race
or other form of difference and so on if
they're thinking
let's say they're right and we know for
example we have many
north america we have india we have many
places where we see people of
of color who are turning to the right
and supporting the right right so that's
not like a
given where all people who are they're
visible minorities or
you know a certain certain type of
orientation and so on
are going to automatically be
progressive that we might associate the
left that doesn't
that's that clearly does not hold it
never really did but
i think there was a time when there was
that more of an inclination in that
direction now that's
basically out completely i mean we still
do see
types of connections and linkages for
example the african-american community
in the u.s
clearly still has a link to the
progressive
democratic party and things even further
to the left in that
in terms of a vast vast majority right
well i know in the social sciences in
particular in universities
there's a left leaning tilt yeah it's
more than just a child but let's call it
a tilt
right and then they will say well we
need more diversity and then
let's get back to race and gender or
like what else is there
race gender sexuality sexuality yeah
yeah
okay race gender sexuality does the core
i mean those are
core i mean as opposed to class right
let's
put in class very important that perhaps
is the one thing that unifies it right
but you're seeing in the university
there's a tendency to progressivism
which i know has become
quotas with regards to representation
and then this will somehow be diverse
affirmative action you mean
in a way yeah yeah no it is affirmative
action it really is that it is the idea
that
historically people have been harmed
and put into lower categories
uh in terms of when you judge
achievement and
they need in a sense to
have society say wait a second we
recognize that you've been put into
those
kind of categories you've been excluded
you've had less opportunities
in the earlier stages so wherever you're
coming to a job or admissions
we need to take that into consideration
in other words
who's on the privileged end is right
white people right
yeah and this is how class reproduces
itself right i mean
actually for my own students i talk
about this all the time i say if you go
to a very good university
let's say mcgill university where
there's a really high percentage of
achievers who have their entire life
had all kinds of resources they've had
tutoring they've had the best schools
and high schools and starting with
elementary school they've had
sports and so on and those students come
in and they're really ready to go
they're really you know they're ready to
achieve they're treated in mcgill
at a very high level of
expectation right in terms of the
reading the assignments and so on it's
very hard to get good grades there right
you have to work really hard so
that's class that continues to reproduce
itself someone comes in
they're producing someone who's ready to
take positions
you know in in the bourgeoisie in in
building class and so on they're
they're ready for that sort of uh
position or
just even in more simple terms upper
middle class if we think about it just
an economic kind of percentages right
[Music]